you ruined my life because
you started you did
you have it
you got to be careful with that hand
gesture because out of context
it looks like you're doing the shake
weight this is what happens when you
this is what it looks like when you take
grandma to applebee's
now you're talking
now i have to say you started it was
just it was just a thing it was a little
quip
you guys did it on another thing someone
referred to you as coco and i thought it
was a thing that they called you
yeah and so you repeated it you got
people chanting it
and now my kids i have
little children who call me sometimes
coco
instead of daddy which enrages me
it's a sample of my power i know
do not screw with this guy
i'm sorry finally he'll blame
something on someone other than jay
by the way all right
i was the guest on your second show
yes in that old incarnation which means
nine months from today
i'll be your second guest when you're on
univision
[Laughter]
we are speaking in espanola
[Laughter]
yeah i made a movie with julia russell
you did that and i'm promoting it uh
we're going to talk about that in just a
second but you talked earlier you made a
quick joke and
you acting as a joke this sample of your
power i think you have great power
i went on your twitter site and you made
a i guess a visit to pixar
yes and you went to use the men's room
and you took a photo of the logo that
signifies men on the men's room door and
check this out
it's woody it's
this is a sign of uh this is incredible
without a doubt clout i have a feeling
though
it picks ours up in emeryville oakland
california my old hometown
and i i have a feeling they find out who
is going to be there
and slap their logos up
if it's if it's the guy from cars guess
what
cars is everywhere the bug's life stuff
is kept in a back room but they whip it
out every now and again
and whenever whenever anybody goes up
there they
they take them me or tim off to the side
and they say
you know your character is the number
one selling toy
so don rickles is convinced he has the
number one seller
it's all a lie you're saying these picks
are people where they're playing sons of
[ __ ]
[Applause]